august is black business month and to
celebrate we want to introduce you to
the game king of las vegas rocky is
outside to show us this really fun set
of wheels hey rocky stop having so much
fun
hey hey mercedes you're distracting me
i'm supposed to avoid the bananas
all right i'm playing mario kart keith
what are you playing i'm playing super
mario smash brothers okay okay so this
is just the outside of game king lv but
i want to show you guys the inside too
and tell us as we walk in what this is
dang king lv is a mobile video game
truck
and um
i pull up to party events and provide
the best video game experience a kid
could even want oh my gosh and speaking
of kids we got your son here on the
truck right now yeah so what inspired
you to bring this to the community um so
naturally i grew up playing video games
and i love playing video games i don't
play so much now as i did back then
um my kids they played
a lot of video games and um
at first i was mad about them playing
video games yeah like go outside go
outside go outside and go play like i
want you to be active right there's a
big market in video games
so
he could be the next gaming superstar we
might have
the next game king yeah on the truck
right now okay so tell people you know
what's the latest in gaming what's going
on what games should people look out for
um all the so fortnite is really one big
of course
of course everybody in the world plays
and of course the normal like the nba 2k
uh-huh that one right there yeah the
john madden the new madden just came out
call of duty's coming out with a new win
um
next month i believe nice and um
i'll have them all you'll have them all
right so how can how can people
come you know enjoy the game or try what
do they need to do um they can either
email me
um at gang king lv gmail.com all right
where they can give me on instagram
gankinglv facebook game king lv perfect
and i have my number and flyers all
around all over the place because you
guys they just opened this truck in may
so they're already a huge success so
we're looking forward to keeping up with
them yes we'll send it back to you
mercedes that looks like the coolest
experience thank you so much rocky check
them out again on instagram at
king lv